hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start warning spoilers ahead today I'm
gonna explain a 2022 American superhero
movie based on the Marvel Comics
character called morbius
the movie begins in Costa Rica where a
team of scientists arrive at a Cave's
entrance the leader of the Expedition Dr
Michael morbius orders the team to set a
trap at the entrance
he then steps forward and cuts his palm
to lure the creature inside the cave to
come out afterwards a swarm of bats
begin flying out the crew Retreat to the
helicopter but morbius stands still like
he is still waiting for something 25
years earlier in Greece the scene moves
to young Michael morbius where Dr Emil
Nicholas introduces Lucian to him both
of them suffer from a blood disease and
the doctor is responsible to take care
of them as they talk for the first time
morbius immediately calls a Milo due to
the last kid who was there being named
that after chatting for a while Milo's
machine suddenly malfunctions and he
passes out morbius uses a spring from
his pen to fix the machine and thanks to
that Milo awakens again
the doctor is flattered with morbius
intelligence and plans to transfer him
to an exclusive School in New York after
morbius departure Milo is harassed by a
group of bullies who later beat him down
until Dr Nicholas comes to save him
long story short the adult morbius
manages to obtain his doctoral degree by
19 years old and he is known for his
effort to cure a bloodborne disease
because of that he is awarded a Nobel
Prize in Sweden but he rejects the award
he goes back to work where he is
treating Anna who suffers from the same
disease as him in the hospital morbius
works with his girlfriend Dr Martin
Bancroft who thinks that morbius is
pushing himself too hard she also
mentions about a gentleman named Milo
who is the benefactor for their project
of remixing human DNA with bat DNA turns
out that he kept the bats from the cave
earlier to study more about them as he
believes that bats could be the cure for
the disease Martine challenges his idea
so morbius immediately tests his serum
on a lab rat to prove his theory however
it dies and Anna starts to have a
seizure they rush to Anna's room and
managed to induce the coma before she
has a stroke shortly after Martine looks
back at the lab and finds out that the
lab rat starts moving they conclude that
the serum Works morbius meets Milo and
Nicholas informing them about the
Breakthrough the two go to the park
where morbius asks Milo for more money
so that he can continue the experiments
on International Water since it's not
completely legal he warns Milo that they
don't have much time left and morbius
has to move fast before it's too late
for both of them long story short the
ship embarks to international waters and
Martine is also present there to assist
morbius after ensuring the serum is safe
morbius decides to conduct a human trial
Martine injects the serum to morbius and
then buckles him up to prevent anything
bad happening a crew member suddenly
gets into the lab and realizes that
morbius is broken free they get into the
isolation room and find morbius crawling
on the ceiling the man tries to shoot
him but morbius reacts faster and
attacks him a group of mercenaries
arrive at the lab and one of them pushes
Martine down making her unconscious
morbius who is turned into a vampiric
monster breaks the glass and attacks All
The Mercenaries
he escapes from the lab and hunts the
remaining survivors after eliminating
everyone on the ship morbius wakes up
and regains his Humanity while finding
out that his body has transformed into a
better shape he goes to the control room
and watches himself attacking the men
and draining their blood from the
surveillance cameras morbius initiates a
Mayday call takes some serums with him
and jumps to the Sea the next day FBI
agent Simon Stroud and Rodriguez arrive
at the ship to investigate the crime
scene they find Martinez still alive but
unfortunately morbius has wiped all the
surveillance footage meanwhile Nicholas
and Milo learn of the incident from the
news
morbius returns to the hospital and
immediately heads over to his lab where
he consumes blood samples to quench his
thirst
from a man who can barely walk morbius
now possesses incredible speed and
strength he gets into the tank and the
bats consider him as their leader he
later discovers that artificial blood
can't keep him stable for a very long
time just before morbius relapses into
his monstrous State Milo appears and
helps him to control himself by handing
him more blood samples Milo learns that
morbius is totally cured now and wants
to be injected with the serum too but
morbius refuses since it's still
uncontrollable Milo insists and morbius
has to expel him from the lab the FBI
agents approach Martine and question her
about the horrifying incident but she
refuses to answer them still that
evening a nurse is attacked by a vampire
creature morbius later learns that a
nurse has been killed indicating that he
wasn't the perpetrator just before he
leaves the agents confront him
questioning him about doing a crazy
experiment on the ship they attempt to
arrest him but morbius fights back and
attacks them he subsequently tries to
flee by climbing to the top of the
hospital with his power but he is soon
apprehended and taken to a Detention
Center
Stroud and Rodriguez interrogate him and
accuse him of killing the nurse morbius
slowly becomes unstable and kindly
requests the agent to bring in the
artificial blood but they leave without
handing him what he asked not long after
he is visited by Milo who gives him a
pack of artificial blood before he
leaves however he forgets to bring his
Cane with him and morbius eventually
realizes that Milo took the serum for
himself meaning that he is the one who
killed the innocent nurse he then
transforms into the vampiric Monster
again and breaks out of the facility
trying to chase after his best friend
meanwhile Milo also becomes a monster
and kills a man morbius confronts Milo
and warns him that the power is
dangerous but he refuses to stop and
attacks his best friend instead they end
up in a subway station where several
officers arrive to arrest Milo but he
kills all of them effortlessly Milo
insists that he wants to fight morbius
who rather chooses to flee through the
tunnel the agents appear at the crime
scene and think that morbius is the one
who slaughtered all the officers on the
other hand Martine is finally discharged
from the hospital in the morning morbius
approaches her in a bus where he
explains his condition and Milo to her
he also asks for her help since the
artificial blood is losing its
Effectiveness to restrain the monster
within him after that he follows two
thugs from the cafe to their lab where
he politely asks them to hand over their
laboratory to him a man tries to stab
him but he is just no match for him the
other thugs run away and he continues
developing a serum that will be used to
prevent him from transforming
on the other hand Milo goes to a
nightclub where he flirts with a
beautiful woman but a tough guy is not
happy with that fortunately he still
manages to control his power later that
evening he follows the man and his
friends and then Slaughters them all the
agents and several officers break into
martine's place but cannot find anyone
there
turns out Martine is working with
morbius in his new lab where they
eventually kiss unbeknownst to them Milo
observes them from a distance the
following day the FBI agents find the
dead Club goers and they learn through
the surveillance camera that Milo is the
real culprit all this time not morbius
after learning about the massacre from
the news Dr Nicholas speaks to Milo who
is scaring him because of his obsession
with the new superpower they then get
into an argument after Milo expresses
his disappointment because Nicholas has
always chosen morbius as his favorite
child over him he attacks the doctor
leaving him severely wounded back to
morbius he eventually has finished
developing an antibody which is harmful
to his vampiric body and plans to inject
the poison to his body and Milos a few
moments later he receives a call from
Nicholas and rushes to his location
unfortunately morbius is too late as he
dies when he arrives
Milo sneaks into their laboratory and
kidnaps Martin using his superpower
morbius manages to locate her and
immediately reaches her but she is also
severely injured by Milo Running Out of
Time Martine allows him to suck her
blood to go after Milo but a small drop
of his own blood falls into martine's
mouth the Furious morbius attacks his
best friend and the fight between two
vampiric monsters ensues they both fly
and crash until they arrive at an
underground tunnel where morbius summons
a horde of bats and uses them to
surround Milo morbius uses this
opportunity to approach Milo and injects
him with the antibody
he immediately loses his strength and
eventually dies just as the police
arrive morbius covered by a horde of
bats flies away while Martine is revived
as a vampire during the post-credits
scene a multiversal rift from the
Spider-Man movie opens up in Adrian
tombs eventually ends up in this
universe he is somehow released from his
cell and meets up with morbius offering
him to team up for the greater good
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching